الناس دائما الى حل كل القضايا الاشكاليه
سلميه عبر التفاوض للاسف الجانب الاخرون
كان لديه نهج مختلف
[موسيقى]
في العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا الرئيس الروسي يبني استعدادا بلاده
للتفاوض بشان ما وصفها بحلول مقبوله
لانهاء الازمه الاوكرانيه لكنه اتهم كياب
ودعمها برفض الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
بدورها اتهمت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه روسيا
بعدم الرغبه في التفاوض ومحاوله التنصليه
من مسئوليتها عن قتل المدنيين بعد اقرار
الاداره الامريكيه قانون الدفاع الوطني
الذي يجيز تقديم مساعدات عسكريه فوريه
لتايوان الصين تقول ان جيشها اجرى مناورات
بحريه وجويه قربه تايوان ردا على ما وصفته
بالاستفزاز الامريكي تايواني مؤكده ان
العلاقه مع عواصمتن تواجه تحديا خطيره
اشتداد العاصفه الثلجيه في مساحات شاسعه
من الولايات المتحده حيث لقي اكثر من 20
شخصا بسبب حوادث السير وانخفاض درجات
الحراره وغرق النحو مليونير
بعد انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن الغاء
وتاجيل الاف رحلات الطيران وليد الرجراجي
ضمن قائمه المرشحين للفوز بجائزه افضل
مدرب لهذا العام مدرب المنتخب المغربي دخل
في قائمه الفيفا التي ضمت 15 مدربا بعد
قيادته اسود الاطلس الى نصف نهائي كاس
العالم وحقاقا افضل انجازا في تاريخ
مشاركات العرب والافارقه في المنضدها